It's a little bit more.
Yes, it is. Right.
[Silence]
Thank you.
Wow.
[Silence]
Salam.
Alhamdulillah.
for
[Silence]
the question and the thing that every
one of us seeks in life, every one of us
naturally seeks in his or her existence.
We seek to be saved from that which we
fear
and to be given or to receive and secure
that which we hope for.
Our lives
are all
lives which
run between hope and fear. Every one
of us, every human being has hopes and
every human being has fears
and we worship Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
out of hope and out of fear.
The difference between the Muslim,
the one who holds in his breastahill
and everyone else
is that we know
and we are taught that all that we fear,
we can only be saved from it by Allah.
And that all that we hope for
it can only come to us
through Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
The thing if you were to sum up any
person's life, anything that motivates
any human being, it is a summation of
hope and fear.
Hope for certain things, fear of others.
This translates to the hereafter as
well. We have things that we fear and we
have things that we hope for in the
hereafter.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us in
he gives us the formula.
The formula
for how an individual
in this life and in the hereafter is to
receive what he hopes to secure what he
hopes for and to be saved from that
which he fears.
He says subhanahua
those who believe
and do not mix their belief
with oppression.
And we will mention and detail from the
Quran what is meant here in this verse
by oppression. So those who believe and
do not
introduce into their belief any
oppression
Those
individuals
for them is full safety
and they are guided and they will be the
guided ones. This is our hopes and
fears. Our fear
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us for
them is safety.
doing all that we could hope for which
is guidance.
The thing that we hope for most is that
we be rightly guided. Not just in our
religious affairs but in our everyday
affairs that we are not left to
confusion that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
grants us guidance
in all of our dealings and every facet
of our lives and that a person may die
upon this hope and fear having been
saved from all that he fears and having
secured cured all that he could hope
for.
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala here
tells us only one type of person
will will secure will will be given
absolute safety
and be granted guidance.
only one type of person and that
is the person who believes elan.
Now this word elan
it is often misunderstood.
It is often misunderstood
in the sense that many of us, many
people when they see the word belief in
the Quran,
what often comes to mind is just
a faith that resides in the heart.
And this is not the true meaning of
belief. If we remember back over the
weeks and over the months previous
weeks and months of talks, we discussed
in detail
how in the Quran there are no absolute
synonyms. Meaning no two words in the
Quran mean exactly the same thing.
Whenever a different word is used, some
different meaning is implied.
And so the question is what is the
difference between
what is the difference between
belief if we would translate it that way
which is to believe
and e which is faith Islamic faith faith
here in the context of the Quran and
sunnah.
Emanuel.
[Silence]
Eman.
What is Eman?
Eman is different than just believing.
Eman, first of all, is only used
for very important things.
You wouldn't use the word
in general
for the most important things you
would use the word ean.
You would use the word
to mean that that you're believing
something important or it could be
something minuscule unimportant.
However, the word iman is only used for
very important things.
We hear this language used with the sons
of Yakub Alis
when they came back to their father with
that
big lie when they threw their brother
their helpless brother into that well
and left him for dead. They put fake
blood on his th on his clothing.
And
they said to their father,
they didn't say,
they didn't say you don't believe us.
They said you do not have faith in what
we're saying. Why? Because this is a
very important issue.
And so iman
in the Quran is not just speaking about
regular belief, believing something
meaning to be merely an action of the
heart. No. Eman
is such strong belief
that
there is no doubt
and it drives the person who holds Eman
to implementing
whatever
this Eman entails.
And so eman
we understand even from a linguistic
standpoint
that eman is something that is in the
heart. It's on the tongue and it's in a
person's actions.
This is eman belief. Now belief is
something that's in the heart. I believe
something I don't believe it. However,
eman
if a person has e in Allah,
this will drive them to speak with this
iman to implement
what this eman entails.
This is why
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala uses the word
im in the Quran
and he's referring to salah.
When the direction changed,
some of the companions asked the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam, what about our
prayers that were prayed to the
direction of al makdis, to the direction
of
Jerusalem.
Are those prayers still valid? Do we
have to make those prayers up? And Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala sent down the verse.
And Allah would not misplace your e.
Your e. He didn't say your salah. He
said your e.
So he used the word eman to refer to
salah. And not only salah but any act of
worship whether it's in the heart on the
tongue in a person's actions
the companions
as
narrated to have said to some of his his
students
subhanahu wa'ta'ala
They would say, "Let's sit and let's sit
and believe for a few minutes." Believe
meaning Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala to
recite the Quran together or whatever it
was that they were intending to do. This
is all part of eman.
And that's why Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
mentions in the Quran in multiple places
that anytime a new verse of the Quran is
revealed, it increases the believers in
eman. Why? Because it brings with it new
beliefs. It brings with it new
commandments. It brings with it new acts
of worship.
And so all of these acts of worship are
all part of amen.
So there's no such thing. It does not
exist where a person believes something
in his heart only doesn't say it,
doesn't implement it and this person is
considered to be a mman. No, a M is not
someone who just believes
that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is is one
and that Muhammad is his messenger. Abu
Jah believed that he did. Abu Jah
believed that Abu Talib believed that
as a matter of fact when the prophet
sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam came to
Abu Talib when he was on his deathbed
and he said to him
sayahill
and I will and I will argue on your
behalf in the court of Allah before
Allah if you aid me in this argument.
And say,
"And he said to him, as is famously
mentioned,
he said, "If it were not for my people
blaming me and saying that I left the
religion of my forefathers and disgraced
my forefathers by by becoming Muslim,
I would have said.
And in many of his lines of poetry, he
has a poem that he had authored and
this entire poem is about the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam and the good
aspects of Islam that he had brought
and he said that if it weren't for my
people holding me back I would have
believed I would have entered into Islam
as well but I can't have it said about
me that I disgraced my forefathers
and
Abu Talib believed believed
that the prophet Muhammad sallall.aii
wasallam was a prophet and a messenger.
He believed that he accepted that.
However, this was not enough for him to
be considered a Muslim.
Why?
Because belief is not something that you
can just have in the heart.
It is something that has to be spoken
and it has to be implemented otherwise
this is not considered to be eman.
Therefore when Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
says
and describes to us the people that will
be given full safety
and full guidance
in this life and in the hereafter.
those who believe and do not introduce
into their belief into their faith any
oppression. And what's meant by
oppression here or transgression is shik
because shik in the Quran is referred to
by Allah as oppression, as
transgression.
Shik meaning that a person worship Allah
and direct any other acts of worship to
other than Allah. Subhanahu wa tala.
This is what shik is. If a person
introduces this into his im, it spoils
his iman. Just if a person has wul
and they pass gas or use the restroom,
it spoils his woo.
Likewise, if a person has toed and shik
is introduced into theirhed, it spoils
theired.
Therefore,
iman is not just something that's in the
heart. I believe and it has no effect on
my behavior. This isn't eman
linguistically
and legislatively in Islamic
legislation.
It is that which resides in the heart,
that which manifests on the tongue, that
which entails actions.
It increases with the worship of Allah
and it decreases with the disobedience
of Allah. This is exactly how the
companions and the defined e in the
Quran. If you say what is
[Silence]
this will be enough for this afternoon.
Inshallah we will continue this next
week.
Subhanahu
[Silence]
alhamdulillah.
Okay.
[Silence]
Allah
Oh,
I
shall.
[Silence]
I Hey,
you
[Silence]
Heat. Heat.
Oh
[Silence]
I Yeah. Heat.
I want to
Heat.
[Silence]
Hey. Hey.
Yeah.
Heat.
[Silence]
Oh, come on.
Oh,
I know.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
forch.
[Silence]
forchech.
orch.
[Silence]
for
Allah.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells our
prophet Sam
in delivering
all revelation that he has received from
Allah to us.
He says to him, "Subhanala,"
and so relate to them the stories
of those who have preceded you, the
stories of the righteous
and the wicked
in order that people may contemplate
these stories,
the stories of the Quran,
the stories of the prophet. sai wasam.
The stories that are found in the
sunnah,
they are not for the sake of
entertainment.
They are not allegorories and
makebelieve metaphors.
These are literal stories,
occurrences through the history of
humanity
and maybe even before
or things that will occur on the day of
judgment.
They are real events.
They are to be taken literally and they
are to be pondered upon and pined over
and contemplated
in order that we can find guidance
in order that we can better understand
this message of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala to us.
One of these stories
and one of the greatest stories that
were told to us and related to us by
Allah in the Quran
is the story of Benny is with Mus
Alisam,
their prophet, their messenger MS and
his brother Haron
and the things that occurred
to Misam
and in their respective eras.
We could divide these two eras. We could
divide the story of Misam with Bani
into two eras, two general times or
epics.
The first is before
they were
taken and delivered across the Red Sea,
before they were saved from Pharaoh
and
after they crossed the Red Sea.
very very similar
to the story of this nation and its
prophet and our prophet Muhammad Sam
during his time in Mecca before he made
Hijra and crossed that desert to what
was known at the time as Ye
and after he migrated across that desert
to what later became Medina
S. Wasam, the city of the prophet, the
messenger,
and was referred to as Medaw,
the city of lights, the city that has
been given light.
Because
before the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
arrived in Yre, it was just another
city.
many cities it existed.
However, when he arrived and began to
reside in Medina, it lit up
not just metaphorically, it physically
had a light to it.
And
mentioned that when the prophet Sam
arrived at Medina,
IT LIT UP.
IT HAD A light to it that we had not
seen before almost beyond description
and that when he passed away that light
left with him.
This is why the story of Mus Alam is so
detailed and so meticulously
mentioned
and it is brought up a lot throughout
the Quran because of the parallels
between our prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam and his story and his time with
his people and Musam
and his story and his time with his
people
in this particular story Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala tells us in
of an incident that occurred right on
the heels of the splitting of the Red
Sea.
Misam
was commanded by Allah during the last
third of the night to leave Egypt with
his people
and to flee towards the direction of the
Red Sea headed towards Beth Makdis
ultimately the blessed land of
Jerusalem.
And as the prophet Musam left with Beni
in the morning, Pharaoh noticed that
they were gone.
And so he gathered all of his people and
all of his chariots and all of his
military. And he said to those with him,
"It's time that we crush them once and
for all. Rid ourselves of these people."
Not only were they oppressing them and
repressing them when they resided
amongst them, but they wouldn't even let
them leave just Bur did with our
prophet sallall.aii wasallam.
And so Musam was directed, given
direction by Allah
by way of revelation
that landed him at the shores at the
banks of the Red Sea.
At the shores of the Red Sea, they have
the sea in front of them and Pharaoh and
his closing in very closely behind them.
And those companions with Musam
out of fear, a weakness,
a terror that enveloped them, they said
to MS,
"That's it. We're here. There's nowhere
to go. Indeed, they are going to catch
us now."
And Misam said,
Musam taught them a valuable lesson that
even when the physical world seems to
close every door and shutter and window
in your face,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has promised
that whoever obeys Allah, Allah will
make a way for him. Even
if he has to pause the laws of physics
themselves,
even if water
is to change its very nature to
accommodate the righteousness of a man
worshiping Allah, it will happen because
that is the promise of Allah.
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
commanded MS to strike the sea with his
staff
and this sea opened up
and they were able to cross
through the sea without a drop of water
touching them.
This is an incredible miracle. This is
something unbelievable.
I want everyone to take a moment and
really appreciate,
imagine deeply
that you are with Musam at this moment.
He
taps the sea with his staff. Seemingly
there's no connection between the two.
And suddenly the sea parts
and a a dry path
is carved out of this sea for M has set
out.
With all the power and technology of
humanity today,
if we were all to collaborate,
all seven or 8 billion people on earth
today to try and do such a feat, we
would be unable to.
And so is with the with Mam.
They're watching this happen
and they cross the sea with MS
and down out of his arrogance follows
them into the sea
and Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala destroys
Pharaoh and those who were with him
right on the heels of this incident when
they got to the other side and they were
headed to Beth Maktis
the land that Allah described to them
through Musam
Not only were they delivered from
Pharaoh, but Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
had promised them the
their residence in Jerusalem and that it
was the promise to them holy land at
that time, not now. They blew their
chance for that as Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala later mentioned.
But at the time it was promised to them.
AND SO ON THEIR WAY THERE,
having just seen
one of the most incredible miracles that
any prophet has ever been given by
Allah,
they came across a people
that were worshiping idols.
It said that these idols were in the
forms of a calf, of a cow.
And as they passed these idols,
they said to
him, "Desate for us
idols, statues that we can worship Allah
through
just these people have idols." Now,
what did they mean by this? What was the
belief behind this? was the belief that
they were going to worship this idol
separate from Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
No,
Musam resided amongst them for years and
taught them the of Allah. What was
intended is that we want something
tangible,
something that we can worship and make
offerings to. Our intention is we're
worshiping Allah. But this is a
representation
for us.
And Misam,
he said to them,
"You are a people of serious ignorance."
And he
made things right and he taught them
right from wrong at that moment.
And he explained to them that we worship
Allah alone without any partners.
But it had already made its way into the
hearts of many of them. And this is why
when Mus Alam
left them in the care of his brother
JUST FOR 40 DAYS, THE FIRST THING THEY
DID WAS DESIGN a calf and worship it.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us that
when they watched those pagans
worshiping that idol,
they almost the visualization is THEY
SOAKED IN THAT shik into the depths of
their hearts. They wanted it and then
they went looking for Misam
to give them something that they already
decided they wanted.
And this, as we've mentioned before, is
the is the formula to disaster.
To believe something and then go looking
through the Quran to find its evidence.
Here they did exactly that. They
believed it. They accepted it. They
judged it as being good. And then they
went to MS to give verification.
They weren't asking him a question. They
weren't requesting. They wanted him to
be a follower to them, not the other way
around.
This story has so many angles to it, so
many benefits
and so many aspects in guiding us.
Now a person may ask what does this
story have to do with us today?
A similar occurrence happened in our
prophet's time saiam
with some of the new Muslims that were
accompanying him after the conquest of
Mecca
in
a companion
known as Abu
Abui.
He narrates, he says,
[Silence]
who says after the conquest of Mecca, we
accompanied the prophet Sam
to the battle of Hune.
And as we were accompanying him, we had
just accepted Islam.
Abu Walt accepted Islam
during the conquest of Mecca. They had
only been Muslim for a couple of weeks
at most when this happened. They were
new. It wasn't all of the companions. It
was a new group of Muslims that entered
into Islam upon the conquest of Mecca.
and they still had a lot to learn and
they still had a lot of their old
beliefs to shed.
And so he said, "We were new to Islam.
We were with him on our way to
[Silence]
He said, "And while we were with him, we
came across a group of mushik
and they had a very huge tree
and they had designated this tree as the
hanging tree, meaning the tree where
they would go and they would hang
certain things on the tree. A warrior
would go and hang his sword on the tree.
A person who needs something would go
and hang something a keepsake on this
tree hoping to get some baraka from this
tree that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala or
their gods would bless them through this
tree for good luck. They believed that
when they hung their swords on this
tree, it would make their swords sharper
with which they could cut down their
enemies.
And so
he said,
[Silence]
And so we continued on our journey
and we came across another big sidra, a
type of tree that grew in the desert.
And so we called out to the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam from the sides of
the path. Oh messenger of Allah,
designate for us a hanging TREE LIKE
THEY HAD a hanging tree the one we
just saw. Now if we stop right here and
we ask ourselves these companions,
these men who just accepted Islam, who
accepted Islam
by saying,
"None is rightfully worshiped but Allah
and left off the worship of their
idols." What was their belief? What was
their intention when they requested a
tree for this purpose? They were on
their way to a battle. They have the
messenger of Allah with them. The idea
sounds really good. It sounds great.
We're on our way to a battle. We have
the messenger of Allah. They were
hanging their swords on the tree to make
their swords cut deeper.
And to give them good luck on their
journey and their battle, we have the
messenger of Allah. We want to have a
tree that does the same thing for us
that Allah will bless us through.
They didn't believe that the tree itself
is going to give them blessings. No,
they requested of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam that he designate a
tree that Allah could bless them
through.
And the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
said ALLAHBAR
for
[Silence]
he said
these are the mistakes that were made by
previous nations. I swear by Allah that
you all have just requested of me
what Bi is requested of Mos when they
said to him designate for us idols like
they have idols.
Then he said something very very
important. He said it is the sunen it is
the habits and ways of the previous
nations.
You all will follow the ways and the
habits fall into some of the mistakes
that were made by previous nations. In
another narration he said
that there will always be people of this
that will make the same mistakes that
were made by the previous nations.
They will follow in their steps to the
POINT THAT IF ONE of them, if a man of
the previous nations was able to insert
himself and squeeze himself into a
LIZARD'S HOLE, AS RIDICULOUS AS THAT IS,
someone of this nation will do similar.
And what is meant by this is not a
dispraise of this nation. THIS IS THE
GREATEST nation of all of humanity with
the greatest of prophets and the
greatest of books. But what is intended
is a warning that we are to read
carefully and learn the stories of the
nations that preceded us in order to
avoid the mistakes that were made by
those previous nations.
[Silence]
Subhanahu waala.
He was happy. Alhamdulillah.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Allah.
Oh,
[Silence]
what
All
[Silence]
for
Allah.
Allham.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Heat. Heat.
[Silence]
So
you
[Silence]
stand shouldertosh shoulder. Close all
of the gaps. muster together. Maintain
the straightness of your rose throughout
the prayer.
Please, if you brought your phone, make
sure that you double check it. Make sure
that it is silent so as not to interrupt
our prayer and our meeting with Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Fore! Foreign! Foreign!
[Silence]
What up?
for
me.
Hallelujah.
Hello.
All
[Silence]
Can have them
Allahel.
I don't the belt.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
for
a
All
[Silence]
for
send me Lord. Oh
holy man.
[Silence]
Allahel
said I want
amen.
[Silence]
Salam.
Awesome.
[Silence]
Brothers and sisters, asalam alalaykum.
Just a very quick reminder. First one is
there is going to be a youth halaka this
evening at 6:30 p.m. in the gymnasium
inshallah. So again 6:30 p.m. tonight
youth halapa and it will be held in the
gymnasium. Second we are coming to the
end of the year and of course this is
the time you start thinking about the
tax liabilities and what have you. Would
you to remember Rama Academy
depends on your help to redirect the tax
liability that is you owe to the state
of Arizona. Again, any amount of money
that you owe as a taxes to the state of
Arizona can be directed to the Rahma
Academy, it doesn't cost you anything
because you're going to pay those taxes
anyway to the state of Arizona. Now, you
just channelled it to a Muslim cause and
that will help us run our school the
best possible way inshallah. So, please
again, brother Jabber is in the back. He
can answer the questions. He has the
flyers in his hand. Start planning for
it now. even though we know it's couple
of months away but please help us out.
Let us plan for success this year
inshallah. Our goal is to at least raise
150,000
from this program. Inshallah,
please donate generously for your masid
on the way out.